good morning john going pizza john
classic today so we're all in agreement
that speed is relative and you say that
you ran those 17 miles slowly but just
so you know to me and probably many of
the people watching this any speed at
all after running 16 miles is
effectively infinite i have not in my
entire life of 41 years run more than
one mile at a time like if you add all
of my running up i bet you get above 17.
john the fact that you've put together
some system of willpower great enough to
keep you exercising and and gaining all
of the physical and mental benefits that
come along with that
honestly it's kind of inspirational like
that's not something i've been able to
do but i feel like you make me feel like
i could do it honestly
bro you are a pretty inspirational guy a
thing i was reminded of when i listened
to the most recent episode of
heavyweight a podcast it was titled john
you are the john in question which is a
little weird i can't believe
that after 15 years of telling stories
on the internet you still had that story
it made me think a lot about how big our
world is and how no one has the capacity
to care about everything um and that's
okay everything is a lot of things and
you can quote me on that john i have a
friend who just got sick with covet and
she's fine she's vaccinated she's young
she's gonna be okay but of course she
feels like absolute garbage and also she
told me that she feels really frustrated
like all of the last two years of being
careful were for nothing because she's
still got covet a frustration that i
understand but and i didn't say this to
her it's just a thing that it made me
think along with the podcast episode we
haven't spent the last two years wearing
masks and enduring lockdowns and being
careful in order to eliminate the
possibility of getting covet as an
individual like maybe at one point
that's what we thought we were doing but
we can't eliminate the possibility
completely it's always gonna be there we
are lowering the probability that any
individual person will get it because
that slows down the spread overall
everyone's got lower odds but some
people are gonna get unlucky and it is
probably true that if she hadn't done
any of this stuff she would have got
kovit the same number of times but even
leaving behind the fact that one she's
vaccinated now so it's gonna be less
severe and two like maybe she would have
gotten covered multiple times because
that can happen the real point is that
we think of ourselves as individuals but
the world acts on us as a collective
think of it like voting in a big
election like i am under no illusions
that my one vote in a red state with
three electoral votes was going to have
an impact on the presidential election
but i still did it because everybody
thinks well my one vote won't matter
then no one votes and that's not a very
good democracy so why this anecdote in
the middle of this video well because
you've been caring about a person for
years who you would have had no
connection with if not for a very
peculiar specific moment in your life
and there's so many other people like
that but it's not on any individual to
care about everything or to do
everything to never get covered to
launch a space telescope to decrease
maternal mortality in sierra leone to
teach every student or plumb every house
treat every patient deliver every
package plant every tree or cook every
meal we do all of these things in a web
of care and if all of us extend our care
out a little bit more yeah that does
make the web catch more things we don't
need to care about everything because
everything is too many things and i
don't need to care about everything
because that's actually a kind of
selfish thought
that's what other people are for like
regardless of your wonderful lovely
depth of care for the person in your
story whether that was there or not he
was cared for and that seems wrong to me
but it is not wrong like don't people
need my care specifically
but no
usually they don't even saying the words
as i have done several times i don't
need to care about everything makes me
feel gross like it is a it sounds
callous but i'm not saying that the
things that i don't focus on in my
everyday practice aren't worthy of care
i'm saying that they don't need my care
i can and need to trust my fellow
members of the web to do their care i
have to because it is a good thing that
we don't have to care about everything
not least because we can't john i'll see
you tomorrow